how's it going with my up prophet my
name is Pierre by welcome back to some
more condom Ned thanks
shut up shut up shut up we've been
through this so many times this place is
so difficult
I'm starting to think I should play this
on each other I I never play xbox never
keyboard and mouse since I was a little
baby boy
and that's that's my only excuse I'm
sorry
alright him again I did play xbox though
and Sega and Nintendo 64 but whatever
alright I think it's these things up in
the sky I am that's it's them they hatch
in your shut up what are you ok we're
fine we're fine
we're still fine just gotta look out for
the sky alright so they don't hatch in
your face you don't hatch you my face
bro
you don't do it you don't do it you
don't you Kenny I don't like this
destroy all the ceiling stocks in this
area and that's optional but [ __ ] that
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] I'm mad at him so Oh Oh
saving content thank Jesus Jason you
damn Kenny oh that's right that's how I
wrong
that's how I get the ladies get all the
head back get all dem head like you you
won't scare me singly don't don't go my
time place what are we doing here Kenny
why are we doing here Kenny the [ __ ] is
go what is day a samurai sword what an
epic that's been a yes it's crazy suck
with Kenny I know that's how I smack him
he's not dead yet
it's not dead yet start dead yet it's
not that it all right cool call we came
from that we came for that that's fine
that's fine
charge charge I'm coming swinging face
so sick of your net boss I invented your
net falls but you weren't out thankful
enough and I was like okay fine fine you
don't have to be thankful but I do [ __ ]
up I don't know where you are get a boot
rate compare it that's right boot
[ __ ] love you all right
that's what you're my you're my homeboy
you're my bro mode bro brewski
and then - all right what the hell
please you know you know what you're not
supposed to be run fast
no no no no no no all right
are you you're done right back
what the [ __ ] I'm glad that told us glad
that's [ __ ] place is over I'm sweating
like a giraffe drop it oh that's right
shoot him hey it's wrong with your face
we'll just lose weight they wanna know
what's wrong with the subway
keep your hands where we can see them if
it may are the game
you don't pick on me [ __ ] stop let him
go why why not shoot him this is Dorland
subject secured up for everything is
wrong with the Sun I don't know if you
get what's wrong about a lot of cables
and [ __ ] going on I don't know what's up
with that
if it's mr. Brown I'll try to fix it
when I reviewed later entrusted your
husband do you recognize the voice who
the [ __ ] is Malcolm Oudin [ __ ] serving a
positive ID yes
Malcolm Van Horn Gotham are that [ __ ]
okay they need to act on this right away
all right yes sir yes sir
barometric [ __ ] tip report to st
music what happened you joking
your joke oh wait I gotta go back to FBI
office
[Music]
okay
no stop [ __ ] yeah that's right sunny
Birds only birds eat them don't worry
about it bro we got this okay who the
[ __ ] said this game was a lot less
scarier than the first one are you
[ __ ] hire some [ __ ] like that
Oh like what other words [ __ ] I beat
cop I really know what I'm saying but my
fingers hurt so [ __ ] bad for [ __ ]
good
search team check-in at least you got
some toilet here room top is secure the
room is ready to give this [ __ ]
animal copy that even you with us
listen you agreed to help us but if you
were to fall back under your action word
box done just fine by me Ethan is Sonia
back off back up [ __ ] you don't tell me
what to do I'll [ __ ] up okay I don't
know what this is oh this weapons we are
going for fist weapons so we can brofist
their faces all night long all night
long she can take it from a girl all
night long all night long shake it i'ma
get one thing straight
mrs. get one thing straight it was an
almost pure I had to help us locate
identify things that come back patio
understood problem what a liability
make my cables are like these I know
what's happening
oh shut up it's so [ __ ] loud
alright okay ah
alright fine fine shut up
all right we're going in from the top
why are we going there oh we're supposed
to go here okay
[ __ ] helicopters making me a desk
what are you doing standing where I want
to go that's a no now you're talking
now you talk finally you uh-huh that's a
good [ __ ] brother I'm jumping in tree
stand clear on the door how the [ __ ] are
you holding this [ __ ] I got this next
box over there don't worry I'm a genius
but if this lock box it what is this
alright don't worry you can trust me
with the gun okay ah mo cool yeah
because why don't we just [ __ ] stock
up before we go in our mission all right
don't worry don't worry I'm a genius
what do you know the guys go guys guys
guys I know it's my first mission don't
where did you go guy not funny
funny what are you doing who are you
identify yourself oh yeah okay what are
we doing
am I supposed to go down there alright
whatever what are we doing
why don't I don't get it what is it oh
they did they didn't bow down they watch
it down oh okay we going down here huh
perfect because this isn't spooky okay
fine
jump what alright little later on the
jump but that's fine a little late on
the pain of that cool little a on the
jump that fine
yep I have a shotgun I'm not afraid to
shoot people with it I invented it
exactly that's good whoever you are
let's shoot the vegetables yeah [ __ ]
use my shotgun I think again good good
using a [ __ ] bedpost but that's okay
what are we doing in here okay let's
keep moving
oh you just wanted me to lurk around
your little [ __ ] yellow [ __ ] [ __ ]
shut up mr. Thomas
[Music]
Oh No we could have juice this oh let's
make some map and get high I'm kidding
don't do drugs bad okay all right
and then when I'm taking a [ __ ] and I'm
hiding in the toilet I didn't even flush
did they what I can fight with a toilet
seat [ __ ] yeah
come at me bro come at me [ __ ] bring
it bring it
come here all right I'm gonna end this
episode here like a pity position
enjoyed it subscribe to come bro today I
see you next episode or bought em for
unmake
[Music]
come on